centuries old churches and palaces have
ornate stone floors that tow craftsman
decades to create with chisels and other
hand tools today factories can produce
similar elaborate designs in a matter of
hours thanks to computer guided
machinery these floor designs are so
interviewed it's hard to believe that
each component is an individually cut
piece of marble granite or other natural
stone whether the design covers an
entire floor or is a single decorative
insert the starting point is a stone
slab it's massive but extremely thin so
it's actually quite fragile workers use
a pneumatic suction poised to position
the slab onto a cutting machine table
the machine is entirely computer guided
it cuts with a jet of water
the water contains particles of garnet
and extremely hard gemstone the jet cuts
by eroding the stone rather than by
sheer force which would crack
workers rinse away the stone grit and
abrasive rezident once the cutting is
finished they use suction cups to remove
the cut pieces one at a time they've cut
squares for this design some will go
into the floor as is while others go
onto a smaller water jet machine which
cuts them into intricate shapes workers
extract these smaller pieces with
tweezers every component of the design
has a number workers label the back of
the corresponding piece accordingly then
they print out a life-size version of
the number design on a sheet of durable
polyester film
[Music]
they tape it to the assembly table to
serve as a template
[Music]
then they lay one piece at a time front
side down onto the template
[Music]
like a puzzle the design slowly reveals
itself
[Music]
you
once the design is fully laid out they
check the pieces together with glue this
keeps them from shifting or separating
[Music]
you
they lay fiberglass mesh over the entire
assembly then they prepare an epoxy
resin specially formulated for stone
setting and spread it evenly over the
mesh
[Music]
they let it set overnight and the next
day they sanded flat the cut stone
design is now bonded together in a solid
unit now they can safely flip it face-up
[Music]
the final step is to fill the joints
with epoxy grout
[Music]
then wash off any excess with a wet
sponge this ornate custom floor insert
is finally finished
[Music]